now we have our asset data parsed we can
use it to render to the screen although
you notice that our previous draw image
function doesn't allow us to draw sub
section of an image effectively it only
took an X and y position thankfully
there's a version of draw image that
supports this ability but we haven't
really discussed it yet there's an
advanced version of the draw image API
it takes in a few more parameters giving
us more control on how we want to get
the pixels to the screen in order to
understand more about this we cruise
over to webplatform.org so we can take a
look at the data the new parameters that
we should be looking at are this first
off we handle the same image object that
we took with a previous draw image API
and then we have the source X source Y
source width and source height
parameters these represent the X Y
position of our chart in our atlas as
well as the width and the height of that
chart in the atlas the destination X Y
width and height represent the position
and size that this small subsection of
our atlas is going to be drawn to in the
output canvas so for example we can set
source X and source Y - 2 - width and
Heights - 30 - 32 and draw to a position
on canvas of 128 128 by 64 by 64 draw
image is smart enough to know that if
the source width and height don't match
the destination width and height -
probably scale the image to match the
desired output size for our purposes and
grits we really don't do any scaling so
for 99.9% of the time source width
height and destination width height are
the same size